un bonsoir très heureux de vous
retrouver pour une nouvelle semaine
d'information locale sur tv 78 nous
sommes le lundi 5 octobre voici les
titres de ce journal la ministre délégué
en charge de la ville nadia est ce sera
notre invité l'ex député des yvelines
reviendra sur le plan de lutte contre le
séparatisme islamistes annoncée par
emmanuel macron le président de la
république a détaillé les grands axes de
ce projet doit depuis les mureaux
vendredi l'inquiétude des salariés de
permettre à joe clayes-sous-bois
l'équipementier aéronautique a annoncé
un plan de sauvegarde de l'emploi qui
prévoit la suppression de 73 postes et
une possible délocalisation du site dans
la drôme l'intersyndicale manifestent
depuis le 21 septembre contre cette
décision
et puis quelques mois après les
élections municipales c'est notre fil
rouge cette semaine le dossier de la
rédaction est consacrée à la fonction de
maire dans le département pour ce
premier numéro focus ce soir sur
bertrand au lion édile de magny les
hameaux
une commune rurale à l'intérieur d'une
agglomération urbaine saint quentin en
yvelines
à suivre également du sport avec un
concours international d'équitation qui
s'est tenu ce week-end c'était à lille
de loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
[Musique]
une situation de plus en plus alarmante
en ile de france concernant le
coronavirus aurélien rousseau le
directeur de l'agencé régionale de santé
indiquait ce matin que 3500 cas positifs
étaient diagnostiqués chaque jour sur le
territoire francilien 203 cluster sont
recensés à ce jour dans la région les
chiffres côté hôpitaux inquiète aussi
avec un taux d'occupation des lits de
réanimation qui a atteint les 36 1% à
paris c'est pourquoi le gouvernement a
décidé de durcir les restrictions pour
la capitale et la petite couronne
francilienne qui passe donc en rouge
écarlate c'est à dire en zone d' alerte
renforcée parmi les nouvelles mesures
annoncées vous le voyez est la fermeture
des bars à partir de demain les
restaurants restent ouverts mais avec un
protocole renforcé limitation est de la
jauge d'accueil des universités des
centres commerciaux la limitation du
nombre de visites en ehpad qui se font
uniquement sur rendez-vous pour la
grande couronne et donc les yvelines
pour le moment pas de changement
maintien en zone alerte rassemblement
festif et familiaux depuis de 30
personnes interdits et les préfets
peuvent prendre des mesures
complémentaires dans le département par
exemple le port du masque est
obligatoire aux abords des gares et
écoles des mesures qui sont en vigueur
pour un minimum de 15 jours
ce à quoi nous devons nous attaquer
c'est le séparatisme islamistes plus
d'une heure de discours vendredi aux
mureaux pour présenter la république en
acte un projet de loi visant à lutter
contre les séparatistes mais vous l'avez
entendu notamment et principalement
contre le séparatisme islamistes et pour
revenir sur ce discours du président de
la république nadir est avec moi en
visio bonsoir bonsoir merci d'être avec
nous vous êtes la ministre déléguée
chargée de la ville et que ce député des
yvelines de la 11e circonscription
emmanuel macron l'a dit lors de son
discours la république a construit son
propre séparatisme de par la
ghettoïsation en concentrant dans les
quartiers la misère et les difficultés
est ce que ce discours c'est aussi une
forme de mea culpa de dire que
finalement la politique de la ville
jusqu'à présent été un échec
je ne pense pas que c'était un mea culpa
de la part du président de la république
je pense que il a dans son discours et
j'étais d'ailleurs présente aux mureaux
moi-même en l'accompagnement avait en
accompagnant avec avec mes collègues
ministres
il a d'abord rappelé le fait d'être
complètement intransigeant avec les
ennemis de la république de tous ces
séparatistes qui véhiculent des thèses
séparatistes tout en accompagnant en
soutenant celles et ceux qui font vivre
la république dans nos quartiers et là
il s'avère effectivement que là nous
n'avons pas été au rendez vous de la
promesse républicaine et quand je dis le
nous jeu inclut effectivement et on
prend notre part de responsabilité au
sein de ce gouvernement mais c'est
surtout un échec je crois de qui date de
deux décennies
nous en sommes à plus de 40 ans de
politique de la ville est aujourd'hui
s'il persiste encore une politique
d'exception dans certains territoires
c'est quelque part il ya effectivement
un échec collectif alors nous avons
décidé de nous y atteler nous nous y
attelons depuis trois ans et nous
continuerons avec beaucoup de force et
détermination dans les mois et années à
venir avec 2
ren axes je vous invite d'ailleurs à
revoir le 7-8 l'hebdo qui aborde
largement ce discours prononcé par
emmanuel macron notamment ainsi on peut
citer l'un des grands axes forts c'est
l'instruction scolaire à domicile qui
sera maintenant strictement limité on va
en reparler dans un instant nadia
aujourd'hui ses bases elles sont elles
sont posées il faut changer de stratégie
concernant la politique de la ville il
s'agit surtout de je pense de renforcer
les dispositifs que nous avons mis en
place le président de la république a eu
beaucoup de faits a pris beaucoup de
temps dans son discours de parler
justement des dispositifs porté par le
ministère de la ville
j'entends par là les sites éducatifs que
nous devons renforcer
j'ai entend aussi le soutien aux
associations de proximité c'est ce que
j'ai commencé à faire en annonçant les
20 millions d'euros à travers le fonds
quartier solidaire c'est aussi tout ce
que nous faisons en matière d'emploi et
le travail qui a été enclenchée avec
elisabeth bornes sur le sujet donc
effectivement il ya un certain nombre de
dispositifs et de mesures fortes qui ont
été prises en matière de politique de la
ville mais au delà des mesures
il s'agit surtout de replacer l'humain
au coeur de notre action et d'avoir pour
porter une politique d'émancipation il
faut déjà commencer par avoir un
discours de valorisation de ce qui se
fait dans nos quartiers
j'y passe beaucoup beaucoup de temps et
ce dont je peux témoigner c'est de
l'énergie qu'il y a dans le quartier
c'est cette volonté d'entreprendre cette
créativité qui est aussi très présente à
travers la jeunesse de nos quartiers et
donc ce que nous devons faire en dehors
de toutes les mesures c'est
d'accompagner cette volonté
d'entreprendre et cette volonté aussi de
réussir dans nos quartiers et je suis
persuadé que nous réussirons tous
ensemble à faire en sorte que chaque
habitant chaque jeune puisse là aussi
évoluer au sein de son quartier mais
avec cet objectif de réussite et de
réussite républicaine alors peut-être
l'occasion de redire en un mot tout à
l'heure de quartier solidaire juste
c'est forcément aussi un discours qui a
suscité des critiques
que répondez vous à ceux qui disent qu
emmanuel macron n'a fait que finalement
jeter de l'huile sur le feu certains
affirment que la loi existe déjà pour
lutter contre les obscurantismes
d'autres aussi qui disent que les
propositions ne vont pas assez loin
qu'est ce que vous répondez à ces
critiques
alors il faut il faut savoir qu'il ya
des professionnels de la critique et que
de toute façon quoique l'on fasse quoi
que l'on dise on sera critiqué soit on
ne va pas assez loin
soit on va trop loin donc ça c'est
j'allais dire habituel depuis trois ans
mais même avant nous sert que ya
toujours eu de la crise critique parfois
les constructive elle nous permet
d'avancer
et parfois elle et destructive ou ont
eux-mêmes de la critique inutile et et
là ce dont nous avons besoin c'est
effectivement de travailler avec les
élus avec les acteurs pour avancer sur
un sujet qui mérite notre adhésion et
qui mérite aussi de travailler ensemble
on ne peut pas aujourd'hui se diviser
sur un sujet aussi grave et qui impacte
encore une fois la vie des habitants et
notamment dans les quartiers politique
de la ville les victimes de séparatistes
ou des thèses séparatistes
c'est aussi les habitants des quartiers
et il est de notre rôle de notre devoir
de veiller à leur protection
donc son discours je vous coupe on aura
l'occasion juste d'en reparler juste
après madame la ministre dans son
discours emmanuel macron a utilisé pour
la première fois le mot de séparatisme
islamistes alors pour décrypter ce que
cela change concrètement ces diaga
tsongo a posé quelques questions à jean
michel schlosser il est docteur en
sociologie au centre de recherches
sociologiques sur le droit et les
institutions pénales laboratoire est
basé à guyancourt écouter ce que dit
jean michel chausseur
[Musique]
volonté de séparer la société de faire
en sorte que la société se fractionne
d'une part et qu'il y a une part de
cette société qui soit totalement
d'islamiser dedans me sa liste dans un
premier temps voire la société elle-même
si l'on en croit un skinny cette volonté
de prendre les rênes de la quick bar
religion en l'occurrence religion partie
d'une action là aussi une religion qui
s'est totalement totalement radicalité
ou davantage miser et qui mêle à la fois
religieux et soit par méconnaissance
soit peut-être par idéologie c'est vrai
que les choses n'ont pas été dit qu on
s'en doute et c'est une bonne ascension
des pavés ne pas stigmatiser nous a
montré du doigt une diffuse en refusant
bons exemples allemands le la réalité
profonde de la situation
oui c'est un message radical oui c'est
un islam police lane et politique mais
celui là est d'autant plus politique
peut être menaçant ses excroissances qui
sont dangereuses pour la société sont
donc je reviens pour la vie je crois
qu'à un moment donné il fallait les
sites et appeler les choses par leur nom
simplement
[Musique]
c'est un choix politique qui est plutôt
de viser la volonté de se séparer de la
république de se séparer d'un choix de
société donc de viser un communautarisme
qui le permet d'utiliser également un
cerf ses rôties et qui serait plutôt un
repli repli sur soi même j'ai
l'impression mais ce n'est que mon
intention il y aurait d'un côté des
religions une visée politique par le
séparatisme
le communautarisme lui est en ordre
sociétal et l'église enclos des formes
de vie de repli sur soi accompagnées
généralement c'est le dit de façon de
vivre qui est hors la loi et je rappelle
si vous nous rejoignez que nous sommes
avec nadia ministre délégué en charge de
la ville est ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec ce qu'a dit jean michel schlosser
est ce que le terme utilisé par emmanuel
macron de séparatisme islamiste est ce
que ça change la donne dans dans cette
stratégie qui a été présenté par le
président de la république alors les
termes déjà il faut rappeler que le
terme de séparatistes utilisée par le
président de la république c'est pour
nommer justement toutes les actions
toutes les personnes qui vise à faire
sécession avec la république et de créer
vraiment une division dans notre société
et les valeurs de notre république
donc il ya différentes formes de
séparatisme
le séparatisme religion est une femme
mais il en existe d'autres
il ya aussi des séparatistes secteur il
ya des séparatistes sur en fait tout ce
qui se puisse sans idéologie dans une
dans une croyance ou ou ou dogs kill
kill qu'ils veulent mettre en avant donc
oui le terme de ces partis je pense
qu'il est approprié dans notre
dans le sujet sur lequel nous sommes en
ce moment est donc là le président de la
république a fait un focus sur le
séparatiste islamiste qui vise vraiment
les personnes qui puisent leur idéologie
dans la religion dans une religion en a
des voyants pour soit mené un projet
politique ou un projet de toutes façons
de séparatistes pour faire session avec
la république donc je crois que c'est un
terme qui est vraiment approprié au mal
que nous souhaitons aujourd'hui viser un
mot sur ce qu'ils ont soit aussi de
votre ministère avec les actions
concrètes qui vont pouvoir être
développés avec ce projet doit la
république en actes vous parliez tout à
l'heure de quartier solidaire c'est un
dispositif que vous aviez annoncé la
semaine dernière avec un fonds
exceptionnel de soutien d'urgence de 20
millions d'euros qui est débloquée pour
les associations proximité ça passe
aussi par là la reconquête républicaine
et d être auprès des acteurs de terrain
ne pas les abandonner
bien sûr il faut aider les acteurs des
terrains parce que eux-mêmes reviennent
en soutien et en accompagnement de nos
habitants donc oui évidemment il faut
soutenir ceux qui font vivre la
république au quotidien et la république
en acte c'est aussi le soutien à ces
associations qui font un travail
formidable sur le terrain travail de
proximité et qui font ces derniers
kilomètres entre les décisions et les
mesures que nous prenons et le concret
et la réalité concrète de nos
concitoyens donc ça passe évidemment par
ce soutien aux associations la
république en acte c'est aussi ce que
j'ai je viens d'annoncer aujourd'hui
c'est doubler les financements aux
formations des acteurs de terrain des
élus haut à la laïcité et aux valeurs
républicaines
aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit que ce sont
deux notions qui sont mal comme souvent
mal comprise et là aujourd'hui et
souvent autour de débats passionnés
donc c'est ce type de formation vise à
replacer la laïcité dans son principe
donc en tant que principe de défense de
liberté individuelle et de replacer
également les valeurs de la république
pour ans
n'améliorant le respect et donc j'ai
doublé les financements aujourd'hui à ce
type de formation qui sont pris en
charge par le ministère de la ville et
par le centre national de la fonction
publique territoriale
et ça ce sont un ensemble d'actes a
parmi tant d'autres on a également parlé
de cité éducative on a parlé aussi des
quartiers d'automne
il ya un certain nombre de dispositifs
qui font justement que cette république
elle est également en acte et il faut
être comme on dit en réponse au
rendez-vous de la promesse républicaine
ça passe évidemment par un soutien
massif à celles et ceux qui font vivre
la république au quotidien et je précise
parce qu'on arrive à la fin de cet
entretien que ce plan de lutte contre
les séparatismes sera examiné en conseil
des ministres le 9 décembre prochain
l'examen à l'assemblée nationale est
prévu lui pour le début 2021 merci
beaucoup à nadia est d'avoir été avec
merci vous êtes la ministre délégué en
charge de la ville et que ce député des
yvelines dans la 11e circonscription
dans le reste de l'actualité la grève
chez l'équipementier aéronautique
permaswage aux clayes-sous-bois depuis
quinze jours les salariés protestent
contre le plan de sauvegarde de l'emploi
décidée par la direction il prévoit la
suppression de 73 postes et une
délocalisation du site dans la drôme les
précisions de justin brasier
l'entreprise permaswage a souffert de la
crise sanitaire
la baisse de son activité a été
conséquente près de 40%
si les salariés s'attendaient à un plan
social avec une suppression de 60 postes
au départ aujourd'hui le projet tout
autre il y a un plan social qui était
prévu avec des plans de départs
volontaires pour une quantité de 73
personnes et ensuite bassila
délocalisations ce fait il y en a un
deuxième plan avec le reste tout le
reste du personnel qui ne veut pas aller
dans la drôme donc si on fait un bilan
ça nous fera à peu près 150 personnes
dans la compréhension face à la
délocalisation la mairie des
clayes-sous-bois a rencontré les
syndicats et le directeur général de la
société je lui ai fait part de mon
accrue moment d'incompréhension des
difficultés qu'il serait amené à
rencontrer s'ils poursuivaient dans
cette délocalisation
néanmoins toute cette décision finale
lui appartient je peux comprendre une
réduction de charges donc une réduction
des effectifs
par contre absolument pas une
délocalisation totale en grève depuis
quinze jours les salariés sont debout
pour montrer leur désaccord face au
projet il espère encore pouvoir stopper
la délocalisation dans la drôme il est
conscient qu'il ya les situations
économiques qui fait qu' il faut des
licenciements ou faut une partie qui va
s'en aller avec des départs volontaires
etc
mais quelle complètement déplacé le site
on nous tous on croit que c'est faisable
pour que ça change c'est c'est eux qui
s'endorment
il faut qu'on reste des offres que l'on
peut qu'on persiste et tant qu'on n'a
pas lâché on va lui dire nous on est là
on restera là
la direction n'a pas souhaité répondre à
nos questions et s'est exprimée vient
munich et elle justifie le plan social à
part une baisse de commandes clients
mais explique avoir initié des
discussions avec les représentants
syndicaux
d'ici le printemps 2000 21 73 postes
pourraient être supprimés et
l'entreprise est délocalisée dans la
drôme le retour du dossier de la
rédaction comme chaque mois focus sur
une thématique pendant une semaine nous
vous proposons en fil rouge cette fois
ci le portrait de plusieurs maires
quelques mois après les élections
municipales lui est un des deux seuls
édile de gauche au sein de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines bertrand au lion est à la tête
de magny les hameaux depuis 2012
il vient d'entamer son troisième mandat
mélanie poquet une écharpe remise par
son conseil municipal pour la troisième
fois en mai dernier bertrand au lion est
réélu au poste de maire de magny les
hameaux
un siège qu'il occupe depuis 2012 à
l'âge de 36 ans et la démission de
jacques l'odieuse ça a été une
proposition qui m'a été faite il y
réfléchit on a discuté aussi ensuite
avec l'ensemble de l'équipe il y avait
aussi d'autres choix qui était possible
finalement on va il y a eu un
rassemblement autour de mon nom pour
pour mener les choses et être mère après
ça reste un travail d'équipé je compare
toujours une fonction de maire à une
fonction de bénévoles on se met à
disposition des autres
élus communautaires depuis 2016 bertron
lyon et depuis ce mois de juillet
vice-présidente saint quentin en
yvelines en charge des espaces verts et
de l'agriculture une délégation à
l'image de sa commune magny les hameaux
porte une double identité urbaine et
rurale
on a toujours cette image en effet très
rural écoutez c'est la caractéristique
du territoire c'est c'est un atout pour
le bien vivre sur notre territoire
c'est un atout parce que c'est aussi à
échelle humaine on dit souvent magny les
hameaux et un peu particulier où on n'y
fait pas forcément les mêmes choses ou
de la même façon qu ailleurs c'est pas
grave c'est c'est peut-être exemplaire
justement de réussir à maintenir cette
multipolarité à l'intérieur d'une
agglomération qui a souvent été vu comme
un mastodonte s'il est engagé
politiquement depuis 17 ans pour la
commune bertrand au lion a choisi de
garder un pied dans le monde
professionnel
entré en 1999 à la fédération française
de cyclotourisme
il en est aujourd'hui le directeur de la
communication je suis passionné de vélo
depuis longtemps j'en ai fait mon métier
tout simplement
alors c'est une chance parce que c'est
ce que je souhaite d'ailleurs à tout le
monde de réussir à avoir un métier qui
plaît pour moi c'est important parce que
c'est beau c'est la vie de tous les
jours c'est à dire que mr c'est pas un
métier c'est une fonction sur un moment
un parti aussi dans la vie on ne sera
pas mais ravis on n'est pas élu à vie en
ce qu'il ne faut pas et la vraie vie
c'est
c'est d'avoir son métier d'avoir son
activité professionnelle engagement
associatif jusqu'en 2001 président du
conseil municipal des jeunes de 1990 à
1993 son mandat de maire prendra fin en
2026 pas de reportage sur le concours
international d'équitation dont je vous
parlais en début de journal mais ne vous
inquiétez pas vous le retrouver dans
quelques instants dans le 7-8 sport
présentée par michael et demi d'euros
afin de connaître toute l'actualité
sportive du département il y avait
notamment un quatrième tour de coupe de
france de football qui se jouait ce
week-end voilà c'est la fin de ce
journal merci de votre fidélité
belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]